[Music]
how fair is the covert 19 booster with
vaccines still a scarce commodity
[Music]
just four percent of people in poorer
countries have received a shot
in the european union it's nearly 70
percent
and yet the eu and other places are
already administering boosters
scientists say the third dose is
necessary to top up immune protection in
vulnerable groups
but the world health organization is
outraged
no more vaccines should go to countries
that have already vaccinated more than
40 percent of their population
until kovacs has
the vaccines it needs to help other
countries
get there too
rich countries want to protect their
people
poor nations
don't have enough jabs to do so
[Music]
i'm ben fazoulen welcome the most
vulnerable are lining up for their third
jab in many countries while the debate
over boosters and vaccine equity
continues
although recent data suggests a booster
for everyone might be key to breaking
the next wave
standing in line for a booster shot like
here at this pop-up vaccination center
in west jerusalem
since august israel has made the third
vaccination of the biontech pfizer
vaccine gradually available to people
over the age of 12.
it is really important to help keep
everyone healthy also i won't get
infected and sick or infect others
and it is a decision by our country that
all have to get vaccinated so i'm
getting it
so in israel like things are slowly
beginning to open up again there's
definitely a mass mandate and people are
still being careful almost 4 million
eligible people out of a population of 9
million have received their third shot
by now just two months ago new
infections with the delta variant
surpassed 10 000 cases per day with
hospitals seeing many more severely ill
patients and studies suggested that
immunity was waning after six months
there is no question that the third
vaccine
the boosters saved israel when we
started analyzing
the new infections and then the severe
infections
based on when they were vaccinated
we came to understand that the most
important issue in the balance is the
waning of the vaccine of the immunity
rather than the delta
israel ramped up its booster campaign
and new infections and hospitalizations
began to slow
in addition the government also
tightened its green pass system the app
that shows the vaccination status is
needed to get into venues like this
health club those eligible who didn't
get their third shot had their pass
cancelled
everybody these days have the green pass
on his telephone and we check it every
day when they come in
it's a little bit sometimes it's
inconvenience but people understand and
we really try to make a safe zone here
and people cooperate the system isn't
perfect compliance by businesses and
people can be patchy
with the effects of the booster kicking
in the country also opened up its
airport for foreign visitors
ben gurion airport israel's main gateway
had been largely closed to foreigners
since march 2020
strict rules include testing before and
after arrival
but the entry point remains a concern
for health officials we cannot celebrate
that we are out of the pandemic
now between the waves our big concern is
how not to have the fifth wave of not to
have another variant coming to israel
israel is now looking at vaccinating
children under the age of 12 and is
closely monitoring how long a third dose
will offer protection
lewis is an israeli physician and was
part of the country's covet 19 advisory
team
much more data is out since we last had
you on the show just how necessary and
how good are these boosters
well i've been as as you just said in
the segment uh
the infection's weird and high of over
ten thousand eu infections per day and
the health system was strained and with
hundreds of severe covert cases and
deaths were rising too that was when the
booster campaign was initiated and and
now um the infection level is very low
and severe cases and death of plummeted
so i would say it was very effective
why is the immune response after this
booster so much stronger than after the
first or second vaccination
so this is an interesting phenomenon
that we've seen in other vaccines and
even um with the kovi vaccine there is
data that shows that people who have
received the first two
doses um with a larger dosing interval
of 10 weeks versus three weeks as a
stomach that was seen in the uk for
example the immune response was better
so um
there is some issue of maturation of the
immune response and and each dose
when it's widely spaced adds to that
response and makes it
stronger and more longer lasting
and
uh we heard in that report that doctors
are keeping an eye on just how long that
booster does provide protection when do
you think a fourth shot would be
necessary
i don't know if a fourth stop will be
necessary then but we're going to have
to track that and see um the the data
that the israeli ministry of health is
collecting is very detailed and that is
what allowed israel in june of this year
and you know to notice that infections
were going up and and this data was you
know it was criticized around the world
um
in the beginning
but it turned out that the analysis that
the ministry of health ran um were
correct and we were we were seeing in
fact um waning immunity of the uh
original first two doses and this was a
phenomenon that was later on seen in
different countries around the world so
what i think is going to happen is we're
going to keep tracking that information
and we're just going to have to wait and
see if we do see a new spike in cases
and analyze that information again
if a fourth
dose is necessary could it be adapted to
keep new variants at bay for example
so that's an interesting question does
the uh boost to those have to be very
unspecific um so what we're seeing uh
with the booster shot is that it was
very very effective against delta even
though it was not redesigned
specifically for those uh differences in
in the delta variant versus the original
very original uh
um covert virus um so
the thing is that
even when you do adapt a vaccine to a
new variant um and this is something
that seems with that i've seen with the
seasonal influenza vaccine sometimes the
immune response is already there's an
effect called a phenomenon called immune
imprinting
the immune response is already more
specific for
the original
virus that it was exposed to so even if
the
vaccine is adapted specifically um it
may not incite a
a really specific response um so i guess
what i'm trying to say is that first of
all
it's not even clear that this is needed
and second of all these um variant
specific vaccines are already in
development and testing by father and
moderna but we're not sure how effective
they will be
could you also tell us why a third
bayern tech shot was used for example
and not modern what what difference does
that make
um i don't think there's a big
difference
i know that israel had a large stock of
the father shot so i guess for logistic
reasons um some people were given a
modern shot um
i don't think there's any specific uh
scientific reason to do that as you know
in the us they have authorized sort of a
mix and match strategy where you can get
a different vaccine
even if you uh as a booster even if you
got a um let's say father for the first
two shots you can get different vaccine
for the booster
yeah lewis thank you very much for being
on the show pleasure talking to you
sure thank you ben
here's an interesting question now for
those who may be vaccinated but have
suddenly caught covert is derek williams
my husband was vaccinated then two weeks
later tested positive for covert 19.
could that be due to the vaccine
no but depending on what kind of test he
took for different reasons there are
basically two different types of
diagnostics the most accurate is called
a polymerase chain reaction or a pcr
test now
it works by amplifying tiny amounts of
sargeras cov2's genetic material in a
sample
up to levels where it can be detected
exactly why vaccines can't cause a
positive pcr result is complicated
scientifically
but more or less comes down to the fact
that most of the currently approved
vaccines
don't use a full version of the real
virus
to kick-start an immune response they
instead contain
short stretches of genetic material that
that don't replicate that degrade fast
and cells and that aren't detected or
amplified by pcr
the second class of detection
diagnostics called antigen tests they
work by
revealing the presence of certain
proteins that are specific to saris cov2
they're cheaper and faster but also less
accurate than pcr
because some vaccines cause your body to
produce the coronavirus spike protein to
to kick start your immune response to
the pathogen
it doesn't seem impossible that an
antigen test which detects proteins
might be confused by that
however to avoid any confusion
most commercial antigen tests are not
designed to detect spike protein but
other coronavirus proteins
in addition
vaccines are injected into the arm but
detection tests
they swab the nose or the throat
the cells there are not the ones
producing spike proteins after
vaccination so
long and short vaccines don't cause
covet 19 tests to turn up positive
the presence of the virus does
[Music]
and finally auckland has reopened its
shopping malls after a three-month
lockdown
excited new zealanders queued outside
overnight to take advantage of retailers
early bird deals
the government is easing restrictions as
vaccination rates pick up libraries
museums and zoos are also reopening but
hospitality venues must remain closed
nice to have you with us stay safe and
i'll see you again soon bye-bye
[Music]